this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by expressvpn more on that later
let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing at night pants studios
i am ryan sickler ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media uh
ryan stickler.com and the
honeydewpodcast.com or where you can go
for any and all information related to
myself for the shows
all right i record here at the santa
monica music center uh so if you live in
la and you need musical instruments or
lessons for your kids
you go to santa monicamusic.com use the
code honeydew
they'll wave the registration fee and
i'll give you one free lesson when you
sign up for a package all right
intro is shorter now y'all and uh
if you don't know what we do over here
we highlight the low lights over here we
laugh
in the face of adversity we're showing a
little bit of light
on that darkness these are strong people
these are the stories behind the
storytellers today
first guest here for the first time very
excited to have him on
uh ladies and gentlemen please welcome
felipe esparza everybody
all right
you look good and you look good man
thank you man all right wait where can
everybody get that please plus
listen plug and promote everything your
social media your podcast your merch all
of it felipe felipesworld.com
f-e-l-i-p-e-s world dot com get my
face mask tour merge everything
great felipesworld.com all right and
what's your podcast
my podcast is what's up food podcast
we're already at
315th episode
damn are you really a 315 yes holy [ __ ]
congrats i know that's a
that's a labor of love right there yes
man yeah that's a lot
we've been doing it for a while now
since
[ __ ] i don't even know how many years
that's i mean i know we did about 350
something like that with the crappies it
ended up being like seven and a half
years that's a
you're you're in dude i don't know how i
mean we did one a week i don't know if
you do
what a week dude that's congrats on that
there's
there's a lot of people that [ __ ] i
started a second one already that's good
for you dude
i know my wife and i we had started one
together too
it was called um enchilada casserole
podcast
because my wife is white you know and
that was more of a personal podcast that
when we dumped more you know personal
stuff
like the honeydew you know stuff that
you wouldn't talk on a
on a dude podcast you know yeah exactly
or
a sports podcast where you talk to
bottom right because my wife and i
we were trying to have a baby you know
when we started a podcast
so along the way like we had a
miscarriage
so we dealt with a miscarriage on our
enchilada podcast
we didn't talk about it in our software
podcast we talked about in the enchilada
and um we tried one time and i remember
going to the hospital and we were so
excited
and um a man
like i had kids before but i was not
like present you know
like like a full dad you know so that's
what we're going to talk about
involved in the in like the nothing you
know
so can i ask you real quick were you
we'll get we're going to come back to
that
i'll come back to it go ahead go ahead
so you're at the hospital we're at the
hospital and then you know how many
months pregnant
three four okay then you fought the
heartbeat
and then you go back like two weeks
later and there's no bum bum
you know there's no pump and like the
baby was
already passed away inside you know and
so we have to go through that you know
and like having a miscarriage was like
um
giving birth the same way you know so
that was a
that was that time and then it happened
again a second time
then the third one you had two
miscarriages three
three uh three man sorry it was three
and oh
i was [ __ ] up and now the third one
was the toughest because um
when um yeah when you have a miscarriage
you know you have to um
get the baby out because the baby's not
gonna live it's already dead you know
three months not even a it's a fetus you
know it's done
and we went to this ch this hospital
called um
um praise chair i don't know the name of
the hospital it's in sylmar
i don't know the name of it but it's a
catholic hospital
and very i didn't know that at this
hospital they couldn't do the
miscarriage
because of religious reasons that's
right but
we had to prove that the baby was
already um not living
to take him out because you know that's
the religion
but it was tough man because so my wife
had to go to the hospital because of the
religious the catholic beliefs they make
you
prove the baby is passed before they'll
remember they don't do abortion they
don't want to be involved in none of
that
so they had to um get i don't know man
they had to call
religious people and approve it to take
the
the fetus out and um then they thought
then i we found out at the same time
that my wife had to get a hysterectomy
oh no so man everything was made piling
down
it was the opportunity yeah man so that
we lost
everything right there like no more we
couldn't have a kid and um
i was kind of [ __ ] up it was like
during christmas time
this last year like three years ago
three years two years three years ago
man
yeah and what did that how did that
change you
oh man it's just like when we realized
we're not gonna have a kid
but you have how many
i have three on my own already all right
you have three kids
and i have my house now my kids are um
my oldest kid was born in 88
i think so how old were you how old are
you right now i'm in 50
you're 50 yeah damn you look felipe [ __ ]
i would have never
guessed that whatever
that's right [ __ ] it's not about
the heedies
and the highs you're gonna put up lotion
oh
[ __ ] all right so how old were you when
you had your first kid
when i had my first kid i was like 17 or
18 years old
all right and then how old when you had
your second kid
20 and then how old the third one
24 i don't know all right
and are they all with the same lady no
different moms all different moms
okay i have one with two kids and one
with one kid
okay and you were estranged from your
kids
you split from them or yeah we separated
from them what happened
we were living in like in um this the
pico aliso housing projects
you know that's where i grew up yeah
oh man i had a great you know like i had
a great childhood you know i had a lot
of you also had a wild child yeah
yeah i had a lot of friends and we broke
up you know um
i was not spending a lot of time at home
so she ended up like
meeting someone now like cheating on me
like behind my back for about a year and
a half
like really cheating when you already
had a kid together yeah we
had two kids together oh two at that
point yeah
and um i was getting into a lot of
trouble like a lot of trouble
like i remember um i couldn't be home a
lot
because something would happen in my
neighborhood and
they were just you know how they would
go after they use those suspects
so they knew like who to go you were a
usual suspect yeah even though i didn't
do nothing
i just i just get pulled in huh i stood
out in the crowd because i had looked
like my hair was short and my word vans
instead of caught instead of converse
and um
i remember the police someone had got
killed right outside my like
right outside the house like some 14
year old kid
um someone drove by and shut up the
neighborhood like
and he got hit in the head oh i remember
i ran out of the house to just just you
know
when you're young and you grew up in a
bad neighborhood or wherever you grew up
you hear gunshots
you're going to go outside after
everything's quiet for the neighbors to
see what happened
so we went over to see the body most of
the neighbors and it was just laying
there
you saw it yeah we saw it man how old
were you when you saw it
20 21 okay then
some of us stood there too long so the
police took our names
you know we [ __ ] up we he took our
name to see if we knew anything
we didn't know anything so the police
are going
the next week door-to-door looking for
everybody on that list of their names
to see who their what who knows what
and i didn't know i've forgotten that
they took my name down
so i thought they were looking for me
for something i already did you know
[Laughter]
for some other [ __ ] so as soon as they
opened the door
i ran man i ran out of the back door
and then i ran and did they chase you
no but i thought they didn't turn around
but
i live in the housing projects where
they had clothes hangers
on top of the roof to to um to hang up
your clothes
so you go up the third floor
one and every other building you go
upstairs to the roof
so i ran to the building and i ran
upstairs and i hit for a while
and then they left then they came back
the next day
but this time when i went out the back
door they were they were in the back
door
they're just waiting on your ass they
had to be in the house
i didn't do anything they had to be in
the house and it took me to see a bunch
of photos
you know i didn't recognize anybody i
didn't know anybody at least
i mean i i wasn't i wasn't that far
as a as uh how you say like i'm not a
i wasn't a i wasn't a witness you know
i was just being nosy right there's a
big difference
i'll be nosy
and for anybody out there something bad
if it goes up somewhere
don't stick around man leave just get
the [ __ ] out of there
leave man don't go back because the cops
will show up and start asking for
everybody's id
you might have a warrant that's the day
you go
so the police took me all the way to the
holland back division police department
they showed me a bunch of photos i said
i don't know anything i don't
you know i was watching saturday night
live you know 11 45 you know
and they let me go they drove me back
they talked about how
mean those police were they they dropped
me out from everybody
nah
they let you out and they told me thanks
[Laughter]
so as soon as i got out one person saw
me come out of the car he was like
oh fool you snitching now
and i actually put my head down i said
no man
these fools this like i lied i said
these fools um
were going to drop me off in the wrong
neighborhood right now enemies in right
the wrong neighborhood
so i told just drop me off right here
real fast i know those people
and they see you [ __ ] liar they
didn't believe me so but there was only
one guy who saw me so
so um i was never around
my my girlfriend would always go look
for me you know like where are you at
you know come home
and um i'm never home so she ended up
meeting somebody
and they were like cheating behind my
back for like a year and a half
i never noticed i never thought to think
that someone's gonna
you know you no one has ever cheated on
me before you know you don't know what
cheating is
yeah you know i never cheated like i
didn't ever i mean
me i don't know i didn't chase women
and um i chased a nightlife no
i like to boogie so uh
i love being out man for me
like i didn't have a i didn't go to the
high school partying you know i didn't
party in high school
i didn't go to college to party so you
know
for me man listening to like
let's separate two with my native
american friends and
drinking beer all night and that was the
live
map yeah you you think those like when
you're when it's happening at that
moment you're at the moment
you think it's never gonna get better
than this man like you don't
think you're going to be 40 one day then
50 or 30.
yeah so she ended up cheating on me and
she ran off with that guy i never saw
them again
and your kids yeah and what did you have
boy girl bought two boys boy and a girl
from her okay but this is funny how deep
she was
in cheating she she brought the guy over
to the house
and said that was my cousin and we're
gonna go to texas and then really we're
gonna go to texas
i help her load i hope this guy that the
guy she was sleeping with
load all her stuff inside his car
wait a minute you helped her pack up and
[Laughter]
my saving grace is this like i didn't
give him gas money because i held back
that was where you drew the line i drew
a lion bro like in my back of my head i
was thinking should i give him gas money
dude not only that she she gave me like
a hug in front of him and a kiss
told me she loves me and took the kids
took the kids kids your kids and their
his car dude
and to mexico up to el paso somewhere
and gone imagine though man if i were to
give him gas money
he could have a whole three comedy
specials based on that
like he would have had t-shirts bro that
would have been memes
it would have been not only was that
[ __ ] his chick this guy gave me gas
money
even the sound guys laughing
yeah man
that's terrible dude isn't that crazy
so then what you don't try to track her
down no better when
when do you find out what happened was
she's been cheating on you and all that
when does that come out
um when she started when well she found
i
i found out she was cheating um because
the guy told me
he did he told me right when
he told me right after they had broken
up like you know he
because he felt bad and i remember her
like
no you [ __ ] your back up that day
loading up the chat yeah man
i got something else i couldn't take it
no more man
when i was not having to orgasm it
wasn't feeling good no more oh
he's guilty i gotta tell you help me
he showed me photos of her to him
together and i was like that can't be
her
she's never that happy you know like i
try to joke around you know make it
make a joke about it i remember when she
told me man when
when i confronted her she wore glasses
i remember man i was sad and i just got
her glasses and i broke them in half
oh yeah man so okay so when
the next girl that you have a kid no i
went to rehab
you did before yeah um um i talked about
it on um this is not happening
you know i got into a fight with some
guy eventually when i was like living
you know doing not doing nothing you
know and um i went to rehab
for about a year and um three months so
i lost contact with them the whole time
rehab for a year
and three months cracker are you for
real yeah man i was like 20 or 21.
so even though you couldn't have been a
father anyway
no i thought it was like picking up
smoking crack after they left oh you did
that's it it really [ __ ] you damn dude
why a year and three mo why 15 months of
rehab is it
i was there for like seven months six
months graduated
yeah they gave me a certificate bro
graduate
[Laughter]
the university of crack university of
crack usa
man my diploma was
rolled up real thin bros he goes nordic
heroin addicts at my graduation clapping
hitting their arms
yeah i was there for about a year but
then i i went back home
but wait i'm sorry you said like seven
months you're there or whatever and
and like is it because it's that drug is
that powerful and that addictive that
you they can't let you out no no no i
volunteered
some of these guys that were there they
were they were sent by um
by the court you know or like they were
called um back then
they were called n numbers i guess i
guess you when you get locked up you
started off with the a
and they run through all the numbers
then it's b so i guess when i was
in my 20s there were there were ends
okay
so they were called n numbers and there
were people that were um
locked up for drug offenses so they were
allowed to go to rehab or go to jail
six months six months legit of of um
of our rehab was four months of
sober living which is nine months
or one whole year of jail time so these
guys jumped on six months of sober
three and four months of sleep
volunteering yeah you were like i need
help
i was sent there by father greg boyle
from homeboy industries
oh yeah okay yeah he sent me in there
wow really
okay yeah and um
i was like the youngest i can't believe
back then i was like one of the youngest
kids there
i was 20 something and there was there
people there they're
59 like heroin addicts
like man i was just telling myself i
want to come back at this age
yeah i don't want to be this guy yeah
man in the crane area
giving haircut for five bucks
i had a guy do that he did
30 years in prison like he did a stretch
he did ten
got out without for three months did
another 10.
then got out and then another eight you
know what i mean
this guy caught my he he he gave me a
haircut with razor blades
no just straight like he had a scissors
yeah
and all this yeah he did it with a razor
blade dude like
he was like 16 2 years old dude
he still had to go he's still boxing oh
man
so when i come out of rehab father greg
boyle tells me your daughter being
baptized today
he tells me out of the blue oh okay so i
go over to the
to the um rehab not to to church
wait what daughter she's i thought they
took her to texas
no but they came back oh they did okay
so they came back you know they were
visiting
oh oh they were just they weren't it was
like a texas trip you know but still
all right it still helped them load
their stuff oh
god they could have went for the weekend
a little three-day weekend down to texas
and um i came on a r i came
out of rehab and i was there like i was
home for a while and um
father greg boyle told me they're
baptized in your daughter
and i said really okay so i wasn't even
invited you know i haven't spoke to them
in like in a year and a half now
so i just sat in the back you know and i
watched it all go hap
happen you did yeah my son didn't even
know you were there they didn't even
recognize me
my son passed by and he didn't recognize
me dude what did that feel like it felt
weird
and um then i saw him like hi or reaper
didn't want anybody to know anything
no he didn't recognize me at all like i
didn't even click on here oh this is my
dad
nothing like he saw a ghost like pretty
much
i was invisible and then now i saw my
daughter getting baptized by the
the same dude that i was like watching
the dude um
bat telling my daughter and it was hey
that's the guy load his stuff nah
i wasn't really
[Laughter]
so you know what i mean i put on my
weight left in belton see
anything else to get packed
you guys need help out of the church
here so i i went over there man
and i walked to the church where father
when they were baptized dinner
like before like they were about to
congratulate
them so i just walked over there i
didn't even looked at the people
looking at me because they thought they
were going to go there like kill
somebody i guess
they thought i would do something
violent you know but that was like the
farthest thing from my mind
i went over there and i just held my
daughter for a little while and i gave
it back to them
what was that like weird yeah yeah
so just give it back to them and i went
on my way
and then when's the next time you saw
them like 18 years later
well 18. all right so that's what i want
to talk about because now
obviously in that 18 years you have a
third child is that a
you have a boy or a girl you had a boy
okay how long
after your daughter's baptism do you
have your
next son i don't know man like six years
okay i mean
and and how do what happens there why do
you why are you not in his life
well i'm in his life but always yeah
well the whole time you are okay yeah we
live together and then like i will see
him on the weekends then i would take
him to the laugh factory
yeah away with brother woods yeah
and um yeah he got to see a lot of stuff
okay he knows his dad
so you've been in his life the whole
time but you were separated from your
other two kids for another 18 years so
recently or somewhat recently you
reconnected right
yeah i think again 2007 or
six already what happened on facebook
how who who made the connection my
daughter did she reached out
yeah how was she at the time i remember
16 i think okay
or 17 and what was the first message
i don't remember she called me actually
oh really yeah
because i remember she added me first
because i remember i made a bit about i
said
yeah i was i met my daughter on facebook
she lent me a comment we didn't get the
child support i had to block that [ __ ]
you just came into my life you started
drama [ __ ]
you just said day one your first day
yeah not changed
you are just like your mama so what
happened she called
and said did you know who it was right
away no
what's the do you remember what she said
to you
oh she left the message you don't know
me but such and such i am your daughter
and then we called i called her from the
were you excited
yeah i was doing a show at um i remember
i was doing a show in orange county
with um edwin juan yeah it was someone
it was a good night i had a good set did
you talk to her before or after the show
no before the show oh bad yeah yeah i'll
bet you were excited to take the stage
after that how'd the conversation go was
a good call
i don't remember man but i remember
telling my friends hey man you spoke to
my daughter oh that's cool
yeah but they didn't know she hadn't
talked to her for 18 years
they're probably that's nice good good
for you so then
did your son come around quickly as well
or was it
your daughter first and then it was my
it was my daughter first yeah
how long before your son was reaching
out
um my son and my daughter had been
coming to see my mom
before i met them already all right so
then now one day we all meet up
we're living our limitless i would have
lived being on second and main
yeah i'm living on second in maine i
remember sharing a lot
with another comedian that she was
expensive
you talking about santa monica no i'm
downtown
09 or 8. and what's the first thing
did you see your daughter first or your
daughter and son together when you
finally met up
you know i saw them both and where did
you go i don't remember where we went
we went to go eat wait
i don't remember do you remember what
you talked about
no we didn't talk we just we just nah we
just took quiet we just hung out
it was this quiet meal yeah that does
that feel weird
no no that felt that much to say
you ain't talking for 18 years i guess i
felt normal
yeah man
okay so you reconnect with your children
through social media
yeah and what is the relationship like
now are you guys all spending time
together
are you around each other do you see
each other more oh when i was living at
the loft
it was my son's birthday and he wanted
to have
a um
no we're gonna go have thanksgiving at
my mom's house
so my daughter came over and we helped
she helped me clean up my whole loft
and we baked the cake so i thought that
was the first time we ever did anything
together that's nice
we baked a strawberry cake yeah like a
good ass [ __ ] strawberry cake
i read the whole recipe bro like i let
my daughter know that i know how to cook
so it was about we went to a mom's house
just for every night and um
that was that one time and
we had a birthday party at my my loft
for my son i remember that
because he wanted chicken enchiladas so
have my wife make them
enchilada casserole and we made i mean
he wanted me to make him a cake
and i made him a banana cake
damn are you a good baker yeah are you i
just follow the directions duncan heinz
but you like it yeah yeah but you know
like a lot of direct
a lot of the duncan heinz a lot of the
other stuff
but when you go when you go um look for
for the cake recipe it tells you to use
the box
so yeah you add extra stuff to it like
banana the strawberries
but this is cool um i had a friend that
i was a dj at the time
and he brought his karaoke stuff and my
daughter and i we sang um that grease
song
some are loving happened this way and it
was good like it was like a bonding
moment
and another time my other son in life
we hung out with my daughter this is
funny uh whatever car
so we went on a train to down to
universal city
walk we just hung out
the three of us on the train
i remember asking my son now you think
um
tuesday we think knows i'm her dad
what's your daughter's name tuesday
tuesday do you think she knows
she did she consider me her father and
my son
says well she calls you felipe
[Music]
in 2010 i think 2010
i went last comic standing yeah and
i'm at a barbecue they invited me to a
barbecue before i won
and the mama is there right and the mom
is dating like a woman now
right so she's been wrong since day one
[Laughter]
you know what i mean yeah it's not my
fault
she's just trying to find her just took
a long time to find herself
oh yeah so she was there you know
with her and for the woman that she's
with
i i know her we grew up together like i
grew up like
we grew up but i grew up seeing her yeah
she's really cool
you know i have nothing against her you
know but she i grew i know who she is
you know she's not the same woman that i
i saw now she looks more like a man now
but i know her she's really cool but
when they were together i was like
wow you would think you would meet
somebody out of the projects
[Laughter]
so what was it like for your kids when
you have one last comment
well one last comment standing and i'm
thinking wait a m
so the mom filed for child support the
next day nah uh
the next day 118
thousand dollars for now
man
yeah when you owe child support in
california it's not like other states
it accrues interest so if you owe like 7
000 if you don't pay the whole year by
the end of the year it's 9 000.
[ __ ] and then like you don't pay that 9
000 plus 7
for next year i was 16 plus another 3
000.
compounds on your 20 000. right
so um she hit you for how much again a
hundred for two kids man so um
um everybody nbc was really cool
so they told me that you know they're
trying to someone just filed a child
support case on you
nah and that's it and that and that's
like i didn't know i'd like i didn't
know i was like say what
[Laughter]
don't go there i said i don't know what
you're talking about
oh goes yes i did i do have two kids
somewhere so
then she said well so um
nbc like they coached me because they
were cool man nbc
they told me to go and get yourself
incorporated first
and then we'll write the check to the
corporation and then you can write
yourself a check to the child support
you know where they would just grab the
whole money
and then give me my share right because
they could do that
so i give them i paid my child support
and um
you paid what you owed thousand yeah not
the
much i owe it two kids you that was a
legit number one just throwing up math
that's how much it was damn and you had
to pay that
yeah man in one lump sum one number some
oh man and then i have to pay the 10 to
the agent
i'm just seeing you with the glitter
coming down and [ __ ]
this is what people don't know the story
you know i'm a painting glitter bro
agent i would like pops for regular show
except he played with lollipops i was
paying with confetti
bro i was i was cash broke for the first
six months
like because um you know because i
couldn't get a bank loan i couldn't open
up a checking account back
because of child support because it had
to clear
you know so um
that happened and
my kids and i we started like talk
getting talking to each other more i
invited my
my son to uh to a
a show i took my daughter to a show and
she loved it and
i had to show him by celia once in 2008
i think before last comic standing i
know he was told in a because brad
williams
he was a headliner and i was a
opener somebody was featuring no i was i
was a featured act
and um some other cool comedian with the
opener
and i remember it was fun man we were
all still in the same hotel room
my son my three kids and my wife and her
son and we all were in the same like
we drove to the show together and i
thought that was cool yeah that is cool
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor expressvpn now
we all know how a vpn protects your
privacy and security online right but i
didn't know this until recently
and it's taken my tv watching to the
next level
you can use a vpn to unlock movies and
shows that are only available
in other countries over the weekend i
use expressvpn to binge doctor who on uk
netflix all right it was so simple i
just fired up the expressvpn app
i changed my location in the uk i
refreshed netflix and boom that's it
expressvpn hide your ip address and lets
you control where you want sites to
think you're located so
you can choose from almost 100 different
countries now just think about
all the netflix libraries you can go
through you if you love anime
you can go use expressvpn to access
japanese netflix and be spirited away
japanese netflix y'all but it's not just
netflix expressvpn works with any
streaming service hulu bbc iplayer
youtube
you name it there are hundreds of vpns
out there but the reason i use
expressvpn to watch shows is it's
ridiculously fast
all right there's never any buffering or
lag and you can stream in hd no problem
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices your phones your media
consoles your smart tvs and more
so you can watch what you want on the go
on the big screen wherever
you are if you visit my special link
right now expressvpn.com
honeydew you get an extra three months
of expressvpn for free that's three
months for free
support the show watch what you want and
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
honeydew that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
what's your favorite thing about being a
dad now at 50.
i don't know
maybe it's your honesty
i mean i i love them around you know my
daughter and myself how old are they all
now my son just had a
he had a baby oh you're a grandfather
yeah my damn dude are you my son had a
baby like
he's seven or eight or nine years old
okay
and my daughter she just came back from
sweden well you've been a grandfather
yeah my daughter came from she was
living in sweden
for about a year and two years she had a
baby and
her her man her baby daddy lived in
sweden so they were both
she was living in sweden for about two
years
then she came back during a pandemic
crazy yeah it is
but it was crazy man cause my daughter
is sick right now or my daughter has um
she has um she told me why it was crazy
man like
we we're talking about zoom my wife my
daughter has um
breast cancer oh no and it's sort of
it's like terminal
it's like on her it's in her bones
already no yeah
it wasn't a it was a saddest zoom what
the status zoom call ever
your daughter's got terminal breast
cancer right now yeah they give her like
10 years to live or 15 there's nothing
with medication
what's in her bones i don't know i don't
know about breast cancer ai you know
but cancer itself i mean she's got 10 to
50 how old is she now
she's 89
30. oh man that's yeah she cut it young
man
so when you're ladies listening right
now you're in your 20s go check them
boobs yes get your titties checked
because she didn't
find out so like she just felt like
weird you know one day and then all of a
sudden they told her
but um she was living in sweden because
that first one they found out i said
stay in sweden everything's free
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah dude i said
stay in school
for you here stay in sweden everything's
free
and um all her chemo was done in um
in um sweden her medicine and all that i
don't think she paid
a dime wow and um that's the way it
should be but the hardest part with her
cause she had um
she needed a place to stay now i don't
think her man worked that out
dude there were no apartments in sweden
really there's not one apartment in
sweden
like it is easy like you know there's no
apartments in sweden like
it's not like like there are people when
people in sweden who
have an apartment it's like those people
like in new york
who never leave right they hold it they
hold it they like even if they
move somewhere else they still hold the
apartment and it's illegal
to um sublet it but people still sublet
but there are no apartments in sweden
so that's why she came back so now are
you trying to spend
as much time together as you can yes um
we spend um our first christmas together
wow yeah her and my grandson was that
nice did you have a good time doing that
it was cool it's cool too because you
have a grandson that probably still
believes in
santa and you get that all over again
he's two yeah and um
yeah i have to buy my daughter a wig
because she's bald now a cool
that way was expensive but you know
you should get her a wig like you should
sell yours that's what i was thinking
the other day
i was thinking like like you know i was
watching this video about
like somebody someone's daughter had
breast cancer
and then he caught his hair bald his
hulk his hair completely bawled like
in honor of his daughter and i'm
thinking well what the [ __ ] are you too
cheap to buy her a nice wig or what
i'm keeping my hair [ __ ] you got
good hair dude
actually great when i see that like um
when people cut their heads off
in honor of somebody yeah it ain't gonna
help all right sorry
here to tell you right now get away get
a wig man
that was nice you were able to do that
that's the great thing about it you know
that um
i'm gonna point my career where i could
just do that you know have this happen
like before last comic standing
not only that honey i'm gonna shave my
pubic hair off
i'll give you
i'm gonna look like [ __ ] powder oh
that's good that you're there for though
well i'm there we talked when my
daughter left
my daughter came um to visit me last
year during christmas
before christmas and um
we got along and we talked every single
day like
when she went back to sweden before she
came back
every day like good morning how are you
it's weird because in sweden and they
have like a dark dark
dark nights forever you know i thought
i don't know what like that yeah 23
hours of darkness or something like that
yeah so my daughter and i we like speak
every day
since um the last time we saw each other
so yeah she's here now but
when she went to um when she went it's
the first time i told anybody about that
by the way
i don't want to people like oh what can
we do
what can you do yeah you can just love
hard and
that's it man and enjoy each other tell
jokes that's it
that's what this show is all about like
i made her laugh the other day i said
because um
i have a bit now you know like some
because you know like
one of my shows was sold out and
somebody sent me this email
he said can you help me out man we're
trying to get to your show it's my wife
and ninth anniversary and
she has lupus her mother died of cover
19.
my brother was killing a drive-by
shooting is there any way you could help
us out
and i emailed that guy back i said i'm
sorry man but i cannot have that much
bad luck in my shirt
i'm thinking the same thing i'm like i'm
sorry man i'm scared to be around i
don't do
i don't do spiritual cleansings man
they're not
an egg big enough to roll over on your
bad luck family
i can't be i can't be having a good time
bro why everybody laughing i look over
there and
you're feeding your mom bro
i just thought i could not but so if
someone dies on the way home
i'm gonna be blaming your [ __ ] shitty
family bro
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] hey don't bring that [ __ ]
to me
y'all live under a ladder i mean god
damn
i saw apocalypto fear
is a bad disease
[Music]
i can't be looking at your family over
there everyone's telling me that's the
live library bro
now how about your kids does your do
your all through your kids
get together do they talk yeah they they
do actually my
my my sons they they they um text each
other
that's good and their kids do all your
kids have children or just one daughter
just too and that's great your [ __ ]
grandfather you got a lot going on and
you got time that's the other thing you
have time
yeah man you know you have time you
don't have to wake up one day and it's
oh my god you've got time and now what
do you do at that time
and how do you make that count i know
man every single pandemic i just been
taking my acting class on tuesdays
on zoom i got to be on superstore for
three more episodes
before they cancel the show good and
i did a movie with the guest house last
year
oh yeah okay that's right that's right
yeah yeah and that steve burn movie
but i did a movie during the pandemic
was a a mexican actor named
omar chaparro and um it was a box
it was good man is it a comedy or it's a
serious movie
is it i noticed with a certain movie
when they started taking
taking away my funny lines oh really
they were written first and then they
started scaling back yeah and then the
scene got too intense
and then i was like waiting for my line
and then my my
funny line would look more like in bad
taste oh yeah
there's a scene where where um
somebody they're they're yelling at
somebody right
and then somebody gets beat up eh and
now opposed to say something like um
hey brown life don't matter
[Laughter]
yeah that comes across important
[Music]
[Laughter]
um so what goes through your mind like
what do you think about
does uh do you think about what you want
to do and how you want to spend that
time with your daughter
like would it and then you're stuck in a
[ __ ] pandemic so it's not like you
can go places yeah
readily like what do you do i'm more
worried about
like her safety because you know if she
catches it she's done
you know there's no coming back you know
what i mean
she has she already has it'll just help
it'll shorten her time here
right so i'm that's my fear but um
she she stays home right now she's
applying for a bunch of stuff you know
for
um medicare and
cancer treatment all that she's looking
for all that stuff right now here in
america
does it make you think about your own
mortality and
your death and stuff like that man i've
done cocaine off the floor bro
i should have died a long time ago
[Music]
man i love you dude that is great this
is the truth though i bet
it is the truth like when it's time it's
your time it's your time believe me yeah
i'm like uh i feel like some people are
like you're liking you're liking this um
in this um there's
all the old cleaners you know that they
have in new york the old cleaners where
you need that number
and that thing just spins and spins and
spins
and they lost my number bro so i'm just
hanging on
just wait until they figure it out like
oh here it is here
i'm just waiting for somebody said you
know what that's my jacket
you know what i've noticed in my life at
least it seems like
death will come in and it'll sweep it'll
take a few
and then it's gone for a while and then
it comes back and it's these two or
these three and then it's gone for a
while and i'm like
i just don't want to be i don't know
when my time is going to be swept up in
that little
death dust buster but it comes around
and gets you know
like if i worry about like catching
covert you know how good are my lungs
you know yeah can i hang right can i
still hit bows
what about um your father growing up did
you
were you close with your dad yeah my dad
was always there
my dad growing up he worked for a
company called pike
p-i-k-e and he was a uh
arc welder i guess he wore the mask
and my dad was my dad worked every
single day of his life i guess
my dad helped my dad were part of the
team
that that um
that um well did the panama canal
no [ __ ] the panama canal was a project
as an american project but people think
that it was made in the
it was built in a panama now man
that job was most of those metal shops
the middle part of the job
were all melt we were all put together
in america and then they shipped it to
panama to put it i didn't know that is
that right yeah
so they assembled here it was assembled
here in america and then sent
there to be finished yeah the metal
parts were put together in america
the cement was done over there gotcha
and your dad was part of that yeah wow
my mom told me i didn't know yeah i
thought he just went to work every day
[Laughter]
but that was one of those dudes that
would that will get dressed up
uh my dad will get paid and get dressed
up on friday night
and then we will never see him again
till sunday oh really he'd just go out
and
rip it up that's maybe where you get at
the night life
yeah man out like when my dad had on
when he was dressed up you know he was
not going to come back
so when do you at what age for you do
you really start getting in trouble
like in trouble like what kind of
trouble well just in the neighborhood
and running with the wrong crowd and you
know
probably well
you said you were a usual suspect the
one who was saying that getting in
trouble all my friends with
all my friends that were i grew up with
they are
most of them ended up being bad but i
already knew
i was already running with them we were
12 right so we kind of like grew into it
but i didn't go down that path that they
did you know
how old were you when you first got
arrested i i never really got arrested
man i got arrested for like
lying you know like one time i was
afraid so i used my brother's name
okay so i got arrested for his name he
used his name
he had more warrants than me
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] or i would get like a i will
i will be in downtown l.a and i run a
red light you know like walking
and there's a cop there give me a
jaywalking ticket and i throw it away
and then like a five year later you know
that's a warrant i didn't
really yeah they put a warrant out for
you on that i didn't know they put a
warrant out because i don't know how
much you're wearing was back
i want you a jaywalking ticket back then
with a hundred dollars
but now they had a a 70 percent
assessment to it
no a hundred and a seventy percent
assessment of 110
assessment so you have a warrant for 500
but when you get there with the court
charges and everything and due to the
warrant
it becomes 1200. damn you got to make
the money
and if you don't pay it you're going to
jail yeah there on that spot
that day when you didn't plan on you had
[ __ ] to do later yeah
yeah so i got lucky
that what that time like like there were
so many people there for like
for small cases for small offenses
riding on a wall
pissing in public running red lights
jaywalking
that um the judge came i remember the
judge coming out and i was sitting there
first of all i was scared dude i'd never
been in jail before
you know and i remember man how old are
you oh i'm at
20. okay i was sitting there dude and i
remember just
just sitting there in a court
court with a bunch of dudes and then
a bunch of chained-up men came in and
they were all wearing red
we're wearing we were wearing um
civilian clothes but
some people were wearing blue cotton gel
blues but these guys came in wearing
orange
and they had like some of them had red
wristbands and my dumb man started
asking questions
it was all these fools oh man those are
high power guys
and i didn't know what high power was or
nothing dude
so just i'm just sitting there you know
so then one of the dude sits next to me
and he he says he crosses he sees like a
gentleman dude like
everything about him his posture
everything about him look like
he's been to a lot of high-class places
but
it just though it was just the way he
acts but he never been
to no high-class anything he was just a
gentle guy
anyway so we're sitting there chilling
in it and then some black dude is asking
people
if they have zigzags and then i had a
zigzag
and he was going to trade it for apple
right so i [ __ ]
i'll trade a zigzag for apple so i stuck
my zigzag out
and the dude that was just sitting there
like a gentleman he [ __ ] smashed my
hand
away from that black dude and he said
the most racial thing i ever heard in my
life
right in front of the guy and um
and he said just don't give that girl
don't give this guy anything
oh [ __ ] this guy right in front of him
[ __ ] this guy
and i just put my hand down and [ __ ]
right there
and i didn't do nothing i just i was
scared as [ __ ]
i didn't want to i didn't want to leave
now unless that guy said i could leave
so yeah so i wasn't i didn't know there
was
prison politics you couldn't talk to
another racial another race
or nothing like that so after that i
just learned right away not to talk to
anybody
so that dude right there became the only
guy i ever spoke to
and he was just he just told me that um
but the man this guy said some
wild stuff man like a white dude
mexican dude like and when you say high
power was he
high ranking no they were murderers
that's what i'm saying they were all
murderers
oh they were all murderers they were all
of them
they just happened to have traffic
violations too
so they were out and that's when they
got they all came in on a bus
they all came in they came in like we
were already in jail
these guys came in at four in the
morning
and then they were shipped in but it was
crazy man like um
that guy he didn't when like as soon as
that guy said that that guy knew her
right away and
his eyes said i'm sorry and he just want
to buy a business
how long were you in there full eight
hours eight hours
in eight hours i learned everything
there is to know about prison
what's the craziest [ __ ] or some of the
craziest [ __ ] you've seen growing up in
your neighborhood back in the day
i know you came on the crab feast you
had wild stories of your growing up days
i tried to remember um
i saw this guy man this crazy there was
this guy named wolf
you know that that's his gang name his
real name i never knew his real name
this guy was man this guy was he he was
like
he had like little legs we had an upper
body strength
like he had a hit he smiled
and he hit a ruby in his tooth a real a
ruby
like a red like a like you know a bling
bling yeah yeah but yeah it was like a
it was like a gold plated around a white
part but inside the white part
he had a red um ruby and um
i saw i saw this guy man and where i
lived there was housing authority police
department
and there was lapd housing authority
they patrol the housing projects lapd
the whole city
but housing authority goes inside the
projects lapd
cruises outside of the projects okay
but but um housing authority police they
have the same authority of the police
as the lapd they could arrest they could
shoot they could
yeah they have guns and um
so i'm i'm just chilling man and
whatever
man i'm not i'm little dude i'm 12.
i'm at the bus stop just sitting at a
bus stop watching the world pass by
and i see one of ranch is walking
and he's arguing with a police officer
about something
then a police officer grabs him and
tries to handcuff him and then i see the
other police officer
um that guy wolf grabs him by the shirt
and starts pounding him man wolf's
beating one of the cops
yeah man beating his ass
and and then the other cop comes
and hits him in the leg his little ass
legs and he don't even move
bro hey his legs stood up oh man
he stretches the billy club from them
and they're beating the [ __ ] out of him
and
[ __ ] man um i probably peed on my pants
man
watching this dude watching this dude
watching his violins i was in shocked
i was shocked man like ptsd and [ __ ]
watching this
yeah i don't know what's going on
and um i i [ __ ] like
i put it behind me whatever every time i
see that guy wolf i would get scared
like
is he gonna what what else are they
going to do you know
i saw him fight this this black dude
named bro
this black dude named um orion i think
and they were one of those fights bro
like
you ever seen the movie um those street
fights like they live
they live hyper or every way but loose
those kind of fights that last forever
yeah
and um i saw somebody pour gasoline on
that guy wolf
what and the guy said listen man if you
don't stop one more in the cash let
yourself on fire
holy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that man
i was always there when that guy was
about to do violent [ __ ] man
like i was like always there at the
right time for him
and then how i noticed that he had that
ruby was
one time out of nowhere man he just
started talking to me
and he told me you have a girlfriend and
i said nah i have a girlfriend
i was like 15 or 16 years old then he
goes you got gotta eat the [ __ ]
he's telling us he's like a grown man
kind of a 16 year old kid they gotta use
a [ __ ]
and i said and i asked like a dumb ass
how
that's a fair question wow
keep in mind that there's a bunch of
other five other guys
drinking 40 ouncers you know wearing
their fedora hats
their trench coats looking good man you
know
how our 80s ganks were about to look you
know they got their khakis
their stacy adams their hats they're
looking good man
but this dude over there telling me how
they [ __ ] man like he should be over
there with your friends
and he's breaking it down bro and it was
all graphic man like
i hadn't even seen a vagina before but
like showing me you know
he was like he's actually breaking it
down you gotta lift it up man
he goes you gotta grab her lips you
gotta lift it up and then
a little peanut's gonna come out don't
get scared
don't get scared and i'm like what up
and i'm like she and i'm like she has a
penis
she has a penis too no
it's a cleared me home no
once you pull it up when you put the
wings up it'll just pop out now it's
gone
and then it'll pop out it'll just pop
out
so then he just then you go like this
man like when i see the ruby in his
mouth
that is a creepy ass way to find out
how to eat [ __ ] it was gross
[Laughter]
the wings are killing me the wings
yeah man but the craziest [ __ ] i saw
when i was um
i was leaving um a little league game in
1980 or
i don't remember the year but you could
look it up it really happened
um i i i was in san francisco doing a
show once and there was like a liberal
you know those liberal books you know
those um
whatever anti-fascist books fascist book
communist books
you know corporate books whatever all
kind of political books
but there was one book there about a guy
who was killed in my neighborhood a
communist member
named mom david something
you could look it up david mendes or
david
i don't know but if you look it up did
you know him or no
murder of communist leader david
i didn't know he was a communist when i
was a little kid but you knew of this
guy
yeah okay i was riding my little my
little
huffy with a little um
little streamers on the side of the
thing
and i'm afraid i had a pk ripper you
know whatever
and we were just cruising and there were
these guys that would come to my
neighborhood and protest all the time
but we didn't know who they were we were
too young
we just called them the kids the dudes
were the red flag
because they would come with a red flag
okay and but i didn't know they were
part of the
communist party but they would come into
my neighborhood and have protests
in front of everybody and then they
would pass out food
and you know and um check up on kids you
know like if they have measles or
they'll do like stuff like that you know
like um
the winning the hearts of the people
what they're really doing now i know
back then i didn't know so they will
come in and
they'll feed us like oh free lunches all
right
everybody's coming out but then they
start doing their little speeches
and it was all like um anti-government
stuff
but i didn't know this you know i
learned this later on
but that's what they were talking about
we're watching them speak then a bunch
of
gang ban gang members from another
neighborhood i don't know who they were
they were from but they were from the
projects they get into a fight with all
these
red guys you know a bunch of them it was
like a
melee bro like my friends and i
who were there rafa angel
jackie we saw that guy
get stabbed bro like he got stabbed to
death
right there like that right in front of
everybody like he got stabbed by one guy
damn i like this blood everywhere dude
so
as soon as we saw that we got scared and
we took we took out with our bikes
to the other side of the projects
and um we saw like um lapd
you know and um they were doing they
were roughing up someone else in the
projects
but they didn't know what's going on
over there because they didn't know none
of that
so um the next day i went over there
because i had summer school
and there was blood all over the place
they hadn't even cleaned up the blood
there was a lot of blood then i saw a
couple of
communist guys just walking around i
guess they were released from jail
but i mean i saw what i saw
but when i when i read the article in
san francisco
they said that the lapd knew that he was
a communist or they killed them
wait they said what they knew he was a
communist pd killed him
the lapd did it yeah you watched what
you watched huh
yeah they didn't they didn't wow
but this guy had this guy was a leader
of the i didn't know he was the leader
of that group
he was i don't know back then but he was
and
he was also he started another rally
somewhere else where where
he became known for that but um
to this day matt they didn't know there
was communist people
preaching and i would yeah and and boyle
heights
i don't know in the late 80s early 80s
i learned a lot today with you man um
something i ask everybody that comes on
for the first time is uh advice
they would give to their 16 year old
self knowing what you know
knowing what we've talked about today if
you could go back
and tell your 16 year old self something
what would you say
i was i'll tell my 16 year old self to
start writing now
yeah start writing everything that
happened to you
i keep a memoir of the things you'll see
because a lot of stuff i don't even
remember now yeah
that's great um
i'm really sorry to hear about your
daughter oh man that's okay man
we're dealing with that and she's she's
um
every once in a while you know i'm gonna
lie man like i didn't break down today
but you know because
i've been dealing with for the last four
months now and um
the first time was a shocker because it
was like she was sad you know and
you know like you exp you know like so
just
you know like you want to spend so much
time with your kids you know but you
know there's going to be limited now and
it's kind of sad and she's got children
yeah she has a two-year-old a single mom
she's a single mom a single mom and um
one thing about my daughter i know that
she's very strong compared to like how i
would have handled that you know
i would have been like [ __ ] this you
know why me
i would have wouldn't you know you know
how we do it man
as a drug addict you try to find any
excuse to go back to using drugs
so i'm glad i didn't go back to using
drugs this time because yeah it would
have been a perfect time
but um my daughter um
we might start a podcast together
because she wants to talk about it
yeah so we're thinking about doing that
happy great so
maybe we'll do it because her name is
tuesdays so we'll call it we'll call it
tuesday with tuesday or something
tuesday's tuesday and um dude also
imagine how much you're gonna get to
learn about your daughter
just sitting there doing that all those
years and
i mean most people never get that
opportunity yeah
can i ask you a personal question um
will you take your grandson who's going
to take care of her son oh
whatever my when i when my daughter and
i when she told us that she had um
terminal cancer and
it was in her bones already and um
because at first i thought that okay
breast cancer okay maybe
she might lose a boob i saw a lady with
a with no boobs she's still alive
but that's like that was not in their
bones
oh my daughter um she had a plan already
about her her um her her baby
she sure had planned it out you know
that um she's a best friend who can't
have a baby
so right now she's staying with her and
her man
so they have a room for her but i'm also
like
involved too with the son like i might
end up taking them too half the time
yeah
so i'm gonna have you just went through
not having being able to have a baby as
well
yeah now you get to have a grandson live
with you
mm-hmm we haven't told my mom yet but
she's old you know yeah and she has
alzheimer's now so
i want to keep telling her well dude
thank you for coming thank you for
having me ryan
going deep with me on this do uh please
promote
uh everything again your podcast your
merch put your mask all of it felipe
and go check that out [ __ ] it's
not about the he he's in the house
i ain't going nowhere i was born in l.a
if if time gets back for me and i'll
leave i just moved to bakersfield
thank you brother thank you man you got
it as always
ryan sickler and all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
week
[Applause]
[Music]
you